good evening I'm poppy s'more iya
welcome to Peru news this is a bit of a
pity pie related episode I'm not
supposed to give my opinion but man do I
love that guy
our first story come from TC Chandler
who ranks the hundred most handsome
faces of 2019 let's watch look at all
these k-pop stars look at them oh my god
it's only Felix illegal I'm the only one
all right we're entering the top ten
Shawn Mendes three-tiered a pie waiting
father to yoga and swim father to yo get
this man we did it
number two Jung kook won congratulations
definitely discerned you know this is
raining stone I'm not supposed to give
my this is stolen you can't argue with
fact you can't argue with fact this is
the ten top ten top two most beautiful
face you're looking at not me because
I'm popular yeah me patiently waiting
for BTS members and PD PI I feel like
this list is like my make-a-wish for
some reason they're always so generous
to me I mean to PewDiePie
so how does it work is this voted is
that why it I I don't understand
I'm like Tana when she win the
award I don't deserve this guys look I'm
not that dead right there
why are you riding LML huh what's with
these laughing emojis huh
what's so freaking funny huh am I the
only one shocked to see pop beauty
probably the most beautiful person in
the planet how dare you how dare you one
of these tweets is so funny it's saying
the guy on the left so people were
really upset that their favorite kpop
stand didn't make it to the list
so they used me as the ugly example
the guy on the Left got number two on
the most handsome faces of 2019 the guy
on the right didn't even make the list
y'all see the problem they're saying
ugly pretty pies ugly head oh they
literally said it why did they even vote
for him which is also you know an
amazing mean template the guy on the
left got number two or the most Hamzah
faces the guy on the right didn't even
make the list unbelievable see this
makes my blood boil he should have been
number one he should have been number
one god damn it
suck it kpop stands number two baby - we
went from 18 was it - you know what I
just want to say thanks to everyone who
voted for me I really appreciate it
thank you
next dose so basically the way I find
out about all this was that I was
literally googling myself
I don't normally google myself okay
because I would needed a picture of
myself for thumbnail I don't I'm not
dilute sir I swear I don't think I would
go myself what is this now media portray
pewdiepie is a loser to sell his success
story says huge damage it never ends
there's so many articles coming out
lately I'm just like I can't keep up
with this I mean that goes for anyone I
thought it was so obvious when I said
that it's like when you sorry this is a
complete sidetrack by the way just
happen to see this it's cuz I did the
Q&A video and a lot of people had a lot
of responses to that or just echoing
what I said he said this in short
pewdiepie things media portrayed tried
to pretend my as a loser so that his
success story could be sold okay
I mean obviously I was kind of a loser
but not just like epic loser I was
in-between loser
okay there is a thing there is such a
thing don't even try to pretend it isn't
so another thing I mentioned in my past
video was that media always under
evaluates me after all the controversies
before it was like beauty pie make 200
billion and now it's like oh pretty pie
made less than I don't know some other
youtuber I'm like I'm pretty sure like I
don't know their personal business or
whatever but I'm pretty sure okay 14
billion views okay
14 billion views I mean four billion
sorry but then the Sun was like okay all
right well then we over valuate the you
then 54 million in 2019 apparently I
made 54 million guys it's just so crazy
it's every good so it was like
I get that people want to know the exact
number so people are just gonna make up
a bunch of stuff but this thing doesn't
make any sense
it says January I made five point eight
million and then it says it in December
I made two point nine it should be the
opposite because December is usually at
least almost like three or four times
more than January but here they evaluate
January almost twice as much as December
like that makes no sense
and what's the brofist logo what does
that mean I'm so confused so this study
was based this was based on a study this
research was carried out by online
Marketplace on Viacom what is that they
just link to the website I try to find
the study I cannot find it um Papa
s'more eeeh and I do research I am so
confused
nothing even shows up when I search
PewDiePie but my favorite part of this
article is the little fun fact window
PewDiePie scandal you know in case you
forgot you remember this
huh you remember this you remember this
and then I want forgot about this just
in case you forgot we just in case you
forgot we have to mention this also we
made it a bullet point list just so it's
easier for you to in case you forgot in
caves anyone's forgotten it seems to me
that a lot of times when people bring up
bad things I've done
then fans wants to respond to me like
well actually you know he's done a lot
of positive things like look he's done
charity and then the response is like
just because you did charity doesn't
mean it absorbs order yours bad behavior
but it's like well the point is just to
contrast it if you're constantly
bringing up all the negative over and
over and over then yeah you're gonna
paint a bad picture that's the whole
point people aren't saying if the
charity he's amazing that's not the
point everybody why you're only allowed
to make one side of the argument you
would never see a PewDiePie's charity
deeds or whatever like a list randomly
in an article that's just not happening
that's my point I'm not saying what I
did was okay it's just like it's always
there always okay so apparently I made
almost three times more than dude
perfect so there you go thank you the
Sun for not at least under evaluating me
I appreciate that I think that's fair
there we go are they
they they kept going how would they keep
going oh wow all right you know what I
take it back I take back my thank you I
also like the headline from the Sun
before quitting YouTube I'm not quitting
YouTube it's how hard is it to
understand I'm not quitting Jesus next
news
this is pewdiepie related Pianist why
are there so many articles I don't
understand it shows up on the front page
here Swedish youtuber pewdiepie
describes fans in Malaysia and Singapore
as hectic and screamish did you guys
know about this I said there's a week
ago and it's posting now I'm so confused
reset you thinking today about the news
a week ago that isn't really news I want
to bring this up mainly just to clarify
what I said in the video was that I was
comparing fan culture from different
going in the more Asian region compared
to smaller Scandinavian countries you
know it's very very different so that
made me think that that's a train
behavior the reason I was so annoyed in
Malaysia was because people were
literally entering our hotel and it felt
like we couldn't leave our hotel because
people were just looking for us and it
felt like we were being hunted almost
but I will say you know I was being a
bit dishonest when I spoke about
Singapore because actually the first
time I got recognized in Singapore that
was like a huge thing for me because
I've never been recognized as a
celebrity before quotation mark I don't
know if you have footage of that but it
was absolute madness it's something that
I've learned that I I personally don't
enjoy but I would be lying if I said you
know I hated it the first time it
happened especially back then as well
because YouTube wasn't really a thing
back then it wasn't recognized even by
the media or anyone so to see the effect
that had on fans was kind of it was kind
of cool to see you know I just wanted to
point that out I'm sorry if I was a
little harsh to you at Singapore and
Malaysia it's not your fault okay like
that was fun I'm not gonna lie just so
we clear all right
Sorry Sorry I'm sorry next juice alright
this is one of my favorite things I've
heard it in a while because it's just so
funny so there's this new meme called
new guy that trends
this as well when I go to myself new guy
meme trends following controversial
PewDiePie comic I'm just like how does
that relate to me I am so confused so
basically what happened was only ng
pointed out that he saw someone else who
made this webcomic and it goes like this
I won't show the artist because it's
it's besides the point but basically
it's saying hey hey oh what's so funny
new guy
hey that millionaire gamer bro - SH bag
totally got robbed hey hey hey how do
you like it if you were robbed new guy
says oh wow I can tell we're gonna be
the kind of co-workers who become good
friends wow really
hell nah he'll now the thing is like so
this is the person that made the
webcomic
and this person is trying to vilify a
new guy but that person is so tone deaf
they didn't understand that they make
themselves look like an idiot it's so
weird
what's the word for it it's so unselfish
this is the first thing I saw today and
people started parroting it saying baka
it's not like I wanted to be your friend
or anything new guy Oh new guy
later that night Oh new guy if only you
knew we could be so much more than
friends so good great
everyone Helga from hey Arnall if you
guys saw that comic new guy empathetic
caring places himself in the shoes of
his fellow man questions sociopathic
behavior
it was happy when he thought he made a
friend even one lacking empathy he has
all landmarks of a good protagonist if
he were real he'd make a good friend I
want to be friends with new guy he seems
great he's not judging so the artists
also made this comic where she
misinterprets this blonde girl is saying
that she has a girlfriend when in
reality she just meant that she has a
friend that's a girl and then she
follows up with saying okay well sorry
but that is infinitely less interesting
to me okay great
so let's look at that way I don't use
Twitter anymore how's it work
hashtag new guy I just love had this
spawn this new guy thing how can you not
love him he's so cute
I love how they try to make him as a bad
person and it's just like and I love how
his base of probably a real human
interaction that happened over someone
celebrating me getting my house robbed
people who are hurt hurt people ever
since realizing that I swore I would
never hurt anyone the pain ends with me
I really like this message cuz I don't
know anything about this person who
wrote this webcomic and and I really
highly don't want anyone to seek out
this person or anything like that I
think it's more the point here is that
to react in a way that is so I don't
want to boohoo me or whenever I'm
looking at this outside of my own
context but the fact that you know
people who react in this way about
something unjust happening to someone to
me is you know it's not normal they I
feel like it's not normal behavior to
react this way I think a lot of times
when people project anger on the
internet or in what towards other people
it sounds like they're probably dealing
with something their own and they're
just lashing out on other things which
it's not new it's always gonna happen
you know I sound like that guy we're
really haters hate themselves you know
but there's a clear distinction to me
wishing actual harm on someone or
something illegal to happen to someone
as a way to celebrate it even if you
don't like him it's not normal to want
that to happen to someone genuinely like
haha that's the weird part of me and and
and how that line is blurred because I'm
a millionaire apparently when it's not
about the money it's about the personal
space and it's weird how no one
understands that and that's what new
guy's saying it's like well you wouldn't
like it if it happened to you so yeah
man I'm explaining to this poor late but
I hope you understand hey there's really
hate themselves with the point of new
guy is that just understanding that yen
just because people who are hurt hurt
other people doesn't mean you have to
attack them back you know even if they
have a bad take or a bad idea so now you
have this comics about this person being
canceled insult but new guy steps in I
was created to be the part of an
insensitive joke but through love
and kindness you turned me into
something amazing for 20/20 new guy new
guy I just also like it because it's
clearly gone so overboard a lot of these
back and forth interactions on it on the
internet that it's it's nice to see just
someone be like all right from now on no
more of this you know so yeah there's a
ton of really funny fine arts and comics
about there's new and memes about this
new guy I also like this person who
pointed out just how shape language
usually aggressive and active is
triangular and static and trustworthy
are square shape so they literally just
made themself into a villain and this
person they try to make it as a bad
person as somewhat trustworthy it's so
unintentional and tone-deaf that it it
created this really strange phenomena
which I endorse I think it's great when
you're supposed to be the dumb guy but
at the end you turn into the good guy
you're part of the reason I wanted to
delete Twitter because I are so sick of
people just jail yelling at each other
it is felt so unproductive it's like
what's the point of this what's the end
game it's this waste of time and energy
so yeah I hope that spirit carries on it
brought a smile to my face and it's nice
to see as an outside perspective even
though I'm technically and involved in a
really weird way new guy Employee of the
Month so that's it for all the news this
week also World War three is happening
ah and guys for watching I'm published
Moorea signing off hey though hey
[Music]
now you are entering a new era where you
shall craft thy own poop
the hour of fart smells in poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and buttons need you
the diaper you will face but crawlers is
all about
[Music]
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne booty is the game to play I'm not
supposed to have my opinion about that
but the prices
you